[Music]
you can check out his hour-long comedy
special on Showtime Showtime online and
Showtime anytime because it premiered a
couple of weeks ago and you will see him
if you're in Montgomery Alabama of this
very Saturday Gary Owen right here on
the Rich Eisen show good to see you sir
I think you got a large viewership in
Montgomery you have no idea what sales
just sky running place we are all over
the place we are all yeah well you're
gonna be at the Montgomery PAC it's
where you're gonna be
yeah Forman Art Center there you know
Performing Arts Center yeah very good
and then fayetteville north carolina in
milwaukee wisconsin or wince concen as a
previous caller set called it because
they're going crazy right now
you're um you're apparently on James
Harrison's Instagram feed right now Gary
you are aware of that right yeah like an
hour ago okay
why are you want James Harrison's
Instagram feed Gary Owen well okay I'm a
die-hard Cincinnati Bengals fan
obviously he's Pittsburgh you know he
played with the Bing for one year right
i roasted the Steelers like ten years
ago at training camp and okay so let's
stop right there let's take it one piece
of time so you were brought into Latrobe
PA Latrobe okay to roast them by who
whose team hired me to come in and
Tomlin reach out to your agency or your
salmon or there's another comedian at a
Pittsburgh guy named Teague goes by tea
road Tony Robertson so he set up he
called me and goes hey we're gonna come
in and roast the Steelers in training
camp you want to come they they asked
for you I was like okay so I don't know
who asked for me but it was a 2009 and I
went in on James pretty hard and there's
anything safe for work that you could
work blue you work blue oh I listen if
I'm gonna do those football uh roasts
yes I don't want no cameras I don't want
to be politically correct like I used to
roast us see when we pee kara was there
every year those roasts are legendary
with USC players but it was gloves off
it was I said if there was video of that
okay yeah I'd be getting protests at my
show okay
so you wrote so Harrison remembers you
from that and you have you've maintained
a relationship since that day it's love
hey well clearly because he just put on
his Instagram account of a shot of him
sacking and Andy Dalton not cool and
tagged you to say that your bangles are
going to be the only owned four team in
the in the North yes oh I was gonna say
no that's what he said in the North
because they play each other this coming
Monday and I you two might be the only
ones actually getting ready to actually
watch that game but other than that I
have a very the Steelers have very much
become they become are Ohio State than
Michigan no offense
doesn't mean that because your team
what's the word for it right now
crushed Rick blows right oh I'm talking
about the bangles bangles oh it's so
frustrating definitely see the there's
and there's pictures of this and me at
the red carpet when Alabama was playing
Clemson the 2016 national town of game
in Phoenix yes they brought me in to
roast both teams so I roast Alabama and
then I get women in the room once saving
their I don't know I don't know if he's
there or not okay and and because all I
had to do I literally went onstage
roasted Alabama then I got a car went
over to Clemson's Hotel roasted Clemson
yes and it was Saturday night and it was
the Bengals Steelers so should I get
offstage they had a TV in the side room
okay and I'm watching the second half
and when Vaughn tez intercepted and ran
through the tunnel and I'm going nuts
right go nuts and then I got Clemson's
whole team behind me and I'm going over
come on you guys are Tigers wear bangles
what do you gather it's the cat family
and then Jamie Hill from the ball went
delete off Instagram so fast there's a
pinch of me on the red carpet I'm not
even smile I'm just like this I remember
Jeremy hill I mean it was right there
the first win in the playoffs since Sam
watch listen
realize rich is I really the week before
his work went down I blame the Jets okay
if they win they're in the playoffs for
the Steelers aren't and then the big
nose played the Jets and think I was
gonna mop the jet said no I think
Buffalo beat him or something I was like
come on because as soon as I saw the
Steelers that year I went we're both
done because I knew whoever wins that
game was coming out beat up well
everybody always gets hurt everybody
ball Antonio Brown in particular right
everybody comes out beat up and I go
we're done and then you know still just
had to play the Broncos and they were
playing to jvj that was like perfect
always had a list of Bend Bell and I'm
brown and he'd get at least he got a man
at all you'd ever get every last one of
them and then you know he didn't he he's
the one that that tore Le'Veon ACL that
one you gonna tackle right you got them
all yeah I miss them which is okay I
miss that guy so much it was like the
stepson like just do this was the evil
step Danny does not you like touching my
mama no more Garryowen here on the Rich
Eisen show did you play football in high
school
okay yeah your high school you tell the
one to high school in Oxford Ohio okay
they are for know is the first time
they've been for know since 1991 okay
Oxford is where Miami Wally Szczerbiak
walleser Ron Harper body okay I
renewable and you come out and Gary Owen
anyway else I think it covers it that's
about that about covers it
it's the Credo coaches all the coaches
come clear bo and woody McVeigh now
that's right our ball well McVeigh
played played wide out there yeah yeah
that was all you know that video went
crazy at the Super Bowl last year cuz
Edelman and and McVeigh play the same
game against a Kent State that's another
thing Harrison as a Mac guy to James he
but he just out of the blue you had no
idea he was gonna just throw you under
the Instagram bus this morning
you don't feeling good about life come
on your show special out it feels good
yeah I'm hopeful Ben's not playing yeah
Bengals got a shot and then James got to
do this well what do you think
I think we're finally breaking the curse
if it's still it's lined up it's this
game well if the Steelers lose at home
on national television to the Bengals
right and to fault Owen for we would
that's you safely say that's the
low-water mark of the mike tomlin era
and the Esper way it could and let me
tell you something if they keep losing
it could end up being one of those San
Antonio Spurs they had the one bad year
and got duncan remember remember uh well
the robinson was out I know they kind of
tanked the season and they got Duncan
that's that but your problem is that
you'd be doing this in the year the
Miami Dolphins are tanking like they
they are really tanking I mean they are
taking every name anything with a tank
fish army anything they're just taking
every possible tank and putting it on
display so I think it's a year premature
for the tank Lawrence coming out now
that's it it's like it's a pre year
premature Miami two of their peer
tanking for two of this year thank you
for to us so you can tank for Trevor
next year yeah but I would be happy with
the two and fourteen season and we beat
the Steelers twice so why is your your
special hashtag doing what I do call
that way well what am i special I talk
about you know and talk about social
media is if you ever see my Instagram
page and you see hashtag doing what I do
I'm lying that is co or I am lying and I
lie I like lying a lot on social media
okay I'll I'll I'll stand in front of a
yacht be like yeah but take my new boat
out for the day people believe it right
like out literary I'll go to it I'll go
to a football game and just go to
somebody sweet real quick and be like
yeah just chilling in the suite well see
the game then go back in my seat so you
crash people Suites just to take
photographs and put that hashtag all the
time all the time there's one there's
one security lady at Paul Brown Stadium
and Cincy they upmost security guys know
me they're there just be like come on
get with slide Jim real quick photograph
yep everybody Mike Brown the background
careful I don't want to get you kicked
out no they don't they don't take care
of me anyways okay I buy my ticket and
so you shot this in San Antonio man your
about to hit the road to Garryowen
dot-com tickets are available for that
your your in two different cities every
single weekend coming up yeah we started
tour this week with the sewer starts it
starts this week Montgomery Alabama
followed by Fayetteville North Carolina
and then Milwaukee Wisconsin you got
five shows in Houston coming up in
November so and get everybody should
check that out of Gary Owen comm thanks
for coming on man
thank you really appreciate that now I
appreciate you rich know it's been too
long it has when was the last time we
met Gary never I know that's what I'm
saying you know what cuz when you said
that you know I always feel when it you
know when people say to me you know hey
man you know we have met before
yeah and I'll be like I don't remember
and then they get insulted that I don't
remember and it makes me feel like
garbage oh really yes when you're when
you say you know it's what did you just
say to me you're like you know thanks
for conceding you can't see you again
I'm like yeah it's been too long you
just said way too long I know that and
I'm like thinking to myself have we met
before so when people say you know hey
you know good to see you and I'm like
great to see you again
I'll throw it again just to cover my hey
rich I don't know why you were so much
in this honesty thing just lie man well
how does your wife feel about that I'm
saying on your anniversary Instagram a
photograph out of your wedding day with
that hashtag although there's a problem
yeah yeah oh no we're gonna be like on
top of the Eiffel Tower with with wine
just you got to do a ride fellas even
though we're probably at Kings Island
that's nice I like it at Gary Owen
comedy on both Twitter and Instagram
check out again Gary oh and hash tag
doing what I do on all the Showtime
platforms and then go to Gary oh and
calm to see when he's pulling into your
neck of the woods thanks for coming on
man one in three come Tuesday morning
think so huh
Bengals one and three Bobby I'll be I'll
be peeled to your Instagram there'll be
a great photograph get ready Harrison
locker room for some reason holding up
the game ball odd why is David Klinger
in the locker picture good pole right
there for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on VR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app